if you're authentic to
yourself not chasing every [__] thing
and you can [__] do this then you can
[__] win attention is the number one
asset uh Vayner Nation what is good we
are here for another episode of podcast
with friends I'm going to predict it now
this going to be one of the [__]
cooler ones we got some real [__]
Heat at this table some guys really
moving in culture making incredible
sounds and fashion and Trends and so
like we always do we're going to let
people go around the room and say what's
up tell all of you uh out there who are
listening live right now but in the
future on the podcast a little bit about
what they do and then we'll chop it up a
little bit and with twitch we'll maybe
take some questions from youall out
there and we'll go so get it we'll start
with best looking let's
go what it do D gu ice wor vzo you know
what I'm saying Detroit Michigan six M
you heard yep tell everybody a little
bit more so obviously where you're from
and who you are if somebody ask you what
your sound is what you do where you why
you believe things are moving for you
what stands out's let's close that door
yeah I'm from the I'm obviously I'm from
Detroit from the East side from a hood
called Six Mile you know what I'm saying
my sound stand out because it's more so
like like the beat sound like can we cut
somewhere hell yeah all right cool them
beats sound like I made them
[__] in my grandma basement you
know what I'm saying just real gutter
[__] like you know what I'm saying just
real dark ass beats we just popped that
[__] on there you know I feel like
Detroit got a distinctive sound and
we've been pushing that sound for so
many years and the world starting to
like gravitate to it you know what I
mean so I think by everybody else around
the world and other bigger artists
[__] with that sound they like
pushing it more forward you know what
I'm saying so I just think our sound is
distinctive and different and I talk
real Street [__] on there authen Street
Music you know what I'm saying I don't
sound like I'm lying again
no V what up baby bro we got so much
love for you it's so good to see you
You' been good you know that year I've
been great everything good how was your
New Year reging chilling family regular
[__] with the girls good tell everybody
who you are and what you do um Dave East
I'm from Harlem New York City um I rap
act I do a lot of [__] um I feel like
with me my sound is more like
like he was saying it's it's just
authentic you could um you could believe
it it it it identify me where I'm from
my my my style you could you can pop it
in and could tell where it's where it's
coming from type [__] so I think just
the um the lyricism the storytelling all
of that is something I really embody in
my music Dave you you you know before we
get to the youngster here popping up you
really have longevity and all three of
you know this everybody in the room
knows this and everybody watching right
now knows this like it's really hard to
do what you've pulled off you've
mattered for a real minute for sure dud
like why do you think that is I ain't
chasing no Trends I I'm not trying to um
do what everybody else doing if it's hot
you know I don't try to just jump to the
next hot thing I I stay grounded I stay
doing what I do try to keep the same
people around me you know what I'm
saying like so I feel like that keeps me
in my own bubble like my own Inner
Circle yeah I don't really pay attention
to what be going on outside of what I
got going on too much I love it I'm
about to pop off a text to make sure
people tune in tell everybody man n
before I even start myself like it's
it's good to be in this room with y'all
like I appreciate as a fact y too cuz
it's like I I'm from New York so seeing
your [__] way back to being in the same
room it's like it's a full circle moment
and you too I was telling them before I
came here or like before you came in
here that I used to watch the podcast I
remember you brought book boogie in the
office and I'm looking like damn how the
[__] I get in the office how get here
you know and we made it here so it's
just like I appreciate you for that I'm
45 I'm from New York uh but like like
y'all y'all was saying like Y sound is
like authentic to what you do like I'm
not really from like the street life but
I'm I'm from Uptown I'm from Washington
Heights so I grew up around it but like
my sound is more like it's more Vibes
man I'm here to like I'm here to spread
A vibe you know abolutely like we we be
we be doing M pits you know we in the M
pits for My Vibe so like we in a
different world but it's the same world
autic clearly the same world but in a
different world so that's what I do I
run a clothing brand like business type
of thing like besides just music it's
clothes people don't just know me for
the music but that's what Au that's what
being authentic is though you know what
I'm saying being true to yourself and
true to what you got going on and
sticking to you know your wave and your
sound whatever just all around the board
you know what I'm saying no but you know
I appreciate all type of [__] so I'm
over here I'm defin
in there turned up you know when I'm in
when I'm like for sure like me we was
definitely listening to your [__] back
and like I was saying like so I started
making music when Chief Keef was going
crazy like around that time like I
wouldn't say making it but like really
into it like cuz I started listening to
like Thug Young Thug that's my inso free
Jeff for sure enough of this
[__] right so go ahead so that we
all know that era okay and and then like
you know what sparked it you were just
like it was just I just feel like I can
too now you know what it was I was um so
I'm I'm born New York City uh uptown
Manhattan and then my mom moved out to
the suburbs I remember when we were
choing we were talking about it so I
moved out to the suburbs a little bit so
I got like the suburbs in my like world
but I wasn't really like matching up
with it you know I wasn't like I [__]
with the business side of the suburbs
but I don't [__] with how people like
acted out there so I was like you know
what I'm going to take the risk [__]
living with my mom I'm going to move
back to the City live with my grandma
back in uh Washington Heights she passed
away and then [__] just started to work
for me you know I just like I took that
risk you know that's really it good for
you took the risk man thanks you know
it's it's funny but I think you're
exactly right and Dave I I actually saw
a picture of you and I sitting Courtside
together at the Garden we sat saw it in
Social the other day and I made me think
of us that night I was just like
recalling like it's so funny people
throw around offense ticity yeah and we
keep you know when I was growing up
keeping it real it's all the same [__]
and to your point when he when youngster
was speaking about like this is my vibe
the thing that I've always been most
interested in back to suburb
[__] Street
kid language religion income level
there's a reason that people that are
very different can [__] with each other
absolutely and the only reason it exists
is because they're both being authentic
and open 100% the only reason people
that are totally different facts like
real [__] all of us no in the room I see
the head nods I'm sure people are going
to say it in the chat right now the
reason you meet
someone and you're like oh I [__] with
this person and on paper the 10 minutes
before you started to chop with them and
Vibe with them you're like I'm not going
to lie think about every person that's
ever walked into a room and you judged
them real quick and look let's call
Spade of spade you guys are cool
like you know and when you when when
you've got that as your currency you
always feel better then being hip to it
being fresh having it that's like money
yeah it's a
currency and when people walk in just
like the country club with their third
generation money when someone from the
street walks in then they judge someone
that's got flavor when someone that
walks in that physically the way they're
dressed right yeah doesn't look like
they have flavor
they judge as I'm out with that person
but then they sit down on a plane think
about the crazy people you chopped up
with in the last three years on a plane
that's effect and you're like hanging
with like Grandma you're like I'm [__]
and the only reason it could ever happen
is authenticity you being you they being
them yeah thinking back to music and
collaborations in different parts I did
I actually did a a TV show this morning
where I talked about Adidas versus Nike
in the80s and I brought up rund DMC like
why did it Adas pop off like crazy in
culture and I was talking about Run DMC
right and you know just thinking about
these things like different worlds when
[__] rund DMC and
Aerosmith made that music video and that
song [__] went crazy you understand I'm
the old dog in here like the rock and
roll was number one and it wasn't even
close hip-hop was a young baby coming up
starting to make some
noise that [__] came out and it made
such crazy noise but the reason they
[__] with each other was they were
just being authentic and they liked each
other trly is and it changed everything
that is the watershed moment of momentum
for hipop that people don't understand
it
quadrupled Hip Hop's interest amongst
America it took over MTV that [__]
played on rotation pre kids pre-
internet right when there was 36
channels on TV that [__] was on rotation
14 times a day and change the world but
none of it happens without authenticity
and as a matter of fact one of the
things that I've loved the most having
people come through this office Through
The Years whether they're businessmen
who have no idea what the [__] is going
on in culture or they culture people
trying to take it to the next step and
build
businesses is when when people are open
to [__] yeah like right like to me the
biggest reason people lose is are closed
so for example in settings like
this that's corny that's selling out
[__] that I ain't doing that [__] and
meanwhile the number one thing that
artist should do is do a collab with a
[__] K-pop band M but they're closed
cuz they see it as corny right for real
for real that [__] ain't you know one
thing one thing I know for sure is
understanding is universal bro you know
what I'm saying you can as long as you
understand a person as as a as a person
we talking about background where
[__] from clothes jewelry who
had at the heartest ain't about that
[__] we can understand each other
mentally mentally that's all the
[__] need bro I think everything
about just building relationships and
and Building Bridges between with with
with one industry to another industry
that [__] always work every time it
never fa and that's why that Adidas [__]
that's why that rock and roll hip-hop
that's why I went that way they they
closed the bridge that what that nobody
thought would ever connect you know what
I'm saying and they started some that
that let me go around start with you
2024 we're still in it it's still
January I can ask these kind of
questions okay what's something you
really really want to
accomplish but let me give you the
context that has historically been hard
for
you not a goal not some [__] that you
want to pop off some AKA something you
actually want to work on based on your
personality based on the way you move
based on the things you've been scared
about based on things you haven't ially
done well what's something you want to
accomplish in 2024 that if somebody that
really knows you knows you like your
mama is like damn I can't believe he
finally did took that chance I want I
want to get better with uh communicating
with friends and stuff like that like
that's a big one like cuz I got a lot of
people around me and like I'm the type
of person that's like yo you do you
doing me dirty like I'm just I'm going
just keep it cut out you know not even
really cut people out just like I'm
going to let you like deal with your
[__] over there and I'm going to do my
thing you going to have to deal with
watching me do my my thing like but my
my new thing I'm trying to work on is
just communicating better with like
everybody like family too cuz like when
I'm in my own world like I really get in
my own world like and that's like a
problem sometimes cuz then I'm like I'm
only communica with the people I see
like in front of me you know I be
forgetting about the people that's
really like background characters and
sometimes like it's important to keep
those relationships I can't just like
throw it out the window so communication
is like a big thing I'm trying to work
on 2024 like I'm good with communicating
like business show we could talk
business all day long but like but real
[__] but like the keep the problems like
I want to get handle the problems a
little more like a little like more
hands on with that my guy that's a
really wise thing to say for a young dud
that's what I'm trying to do 202 good
for you Dave but and you said history
but if I good good no no that's
definitely that's it that's bet with me
this year um I opened a store up last
year in Harlem um called from the Delhi
and I really want to see how far I could
take that as far as the real estate game
and tell everybody who's watching and
listening tell them from the deli give
them a little 411 what it is um from the
deli is basically One-Stop shop you know
what I'm saying um everything you need
is in there uh I do a lot of events in
there a it's just like a um a social
space type of type of type of vibe
what's it that 145th in St Nick oh [__]
okay on the hell yeah okay how's being
in retail B you learned some lessons
already yeah definitely cuz I grew up in
retail and everybody likes to get
excited about retail and then you start
realizing like the manager didn't show
up and the [__] store didn't open
it's definitely work it's real work
looking at it before I did it and now
I'm in it is it's definitely work but
it's something what most surprising to
you um most
surprising what caught you off guard
like how hard it would be to sustain
foot traffic how managing people
realizing who who who can I really have
working in there yeah that that might be
the hardest I me because I'm not not
running it tell a real story that's
going to make you laugh on this it's
good for everybody to listen so I was
born in the in Soviet Union USSR
immigrated to us when I was three lived
in Queens studio apartment the size of
this eight family members poor poor poor
my dad worked every minute American
Dream went from being a stock boy in a
liquor store to eventually being the
manager to eventually saving his money
for seven years of buying his own shop
I'm 14 11 years later and I get Dred in
I got to work at the [__] you know some
Merchant [__] you know the corner store
day have family business [__] I'm
working at 14 hustling 45 minutes my
dad's store was from where we lived I
spent so little time with my dad at this
point cuz he worked every minute even
though my dad and I slept in the same
house my whole childhood he would leave
before I woke up and he came home after
I went to bed some real [__] and I'm
talking 360 days a year hey bro that's
crazy you said that [__] bro cuz I I I
be feeling I wonder if my son feel that
same way about you yeah and sometimes I
be feeling guilty about that [__] like
damn am I am I hurt am I love man let me
let me tell you something that you might
that might be so let me tell you
something fellas for all and for all the
parents listening right now that are
trying to figure out work life balance
let me give you an optimistic story my
dad did all that I didn't see him all
that much at all he went to none of my
games knew nothing in my life until I
started working at the store at 14 and I
sit here today my dad and I are tight as
[__] I love him the most we're super
tight like sure I'm a human what a what
as I have an 11 year younger brother and
at that point especially because of what
I did for his business he was able to do
more [__] for my brother do I feel some
sort of way sometimes but on some real
real real [__] right I have the best
relationship my pops now that doesn't
work out for some people some people
resent it there's things and if you're
feeling that way I feel that way I work
like crazy you got to chop at it you got
to let me give you a good one then if
both of you feel that way one time a
month when you normally
energetically chemically feel like no I
got to do that show I'm going to take
that business meeting I'm going to go to
the gramys one time a month choose the
kid choose the kid get into the Habit
yeah just like some real hot like NBA
Allstar in Indiana nah I'm this time I'm
going to take got it one time a month
them events is going to be there them
times with them kids they getting old I
look back just was it two days ago was
the 6 year anniversary of my um paranoia
2 album and my daughter's a baby on that
cover it's already about to be eight
yeah it's crazy anyway let me finish
this story cuz you're love this you're
going to love this about retail so now I
don't even know my pops like that plus
my pops has these eyebrows that are
naturally mean looking like this and so
and he doesn't talk so I'm just crazy
scared of my dad right and we drive and
my dad is the reverse of me I'm
extroverted loud he's quiet so we drive
45 [__] minutes at 700 in the morning
and he doesn't say a word quiet right
that's and by the way kids pre phone I'm
just sitting there listening to the
radio like and this my this my first
this my first day at work at the store
too and I'm like and I was already
slinging baseball cards making money
yeah and my dad my mom told me the night
before he's going to pay me two bucks an
hour I'm like this is some [__] like
I'm like I'm going to work for 10 hours
make 20 bucks I sold a k griffy I sold a
Ken griffy card for 80 last week I was
all mad anyway we pull into the parking
lot mhm my dad turns to me in a deep
like Ivan Drago Russian accent and he
goes keep an eye on the employees they
like to
steal that's what was on his mind and
that's what you're learning there's
certain people you can let in there you
know it's just anything that you not
looking at all the time it's like your
kids soon as they got a chance to sneak
off they going to sneak off and do
something like it's a human nature like
you know what I mean you said something
earlier Inner Circle again everybody in
the chat jump in on this and all of you
like you all know this like it's a very
common thing that we talk about in
Street culture in business and
everything in the music business that
inner circles Everything All I Do by the
way my whole world a lot of you got a
little bit of sense it I'm trying to
keep people forever so I can take them
from strangers when they walk in day one
to acquaintances when they start
chopping with me a little bit to friends
when they chop more and then [__]
family absolutely the whole [__] game
that's that's the process of it though
it can't just go straight from one to
family like Gotan of course not that's
why I believe in working with family
everyone says don't work with your
family yeah if you know yourself and you
care about money over everything don't
work with family cuz you're going to
lose your family because you care about
money too much but if you're not just
about paper you should always work with
family cuz you've already gotten to the
[__] Main Place been do it with him
yeah so that's your thing got you my man
what do you got for us for
my thing for 2024 right is to not be so
like so shy about my entrepreneurship
you know I'm saying I make Street Music
I'm I come from the streets I'm I'm a
street guy and I all and one thing I do
I have learned through experience like
when you got so much other [__] going on
it kind of take away from your music and
I love my music so much that I always
end up put in the music over my other
business you're scared to get distracted
cuz that's the core thing I'm scared
from how people going to look at it like
I'm a businessman businessman brother
like I had my first restaurant when I
was 23 years old my first car wash
dispensaries like I own a vape company
we got a chip company I own a juice bar
I got real estate I got I own a movie uh
Distribution Company and I own a movie
film company overall I got a lot of [__]
going on and when I'm busy promoting all
that [__] and posting that [__] and
working for this and working towards
that sometimes like with like with my
fan base and bro got the same type of
fan like we got we come from the street
so we got that fan base they take they
try to they try to dumb the music down
and that [__] take away from it they
feel like damn bro you ain't got nothing
to talk about no more because you got
all this [__] going on or the [__] you
talking about it the [__] this [__] it
Ain it ain't it ain't real or I don't
want to hear it so it kind of Mak it
make me feel like damn can I not be no
business man you know what I'm saying
listen cuz [__] take that [__]
the wrong way let's level up let's let's
take this broad obviously for everybody
who's listening that listens to hip hop
and the culture and understands what
we're talking about we're talking about
the streets [__] with you right when
the streets [__] with you but the
reality is this is a global issue the
number one issue in American pop culture
is we are obsessed not just Urban black
hip-hop culture America we build Britney
up then tore down and we tear Britney
back you know why cuz we really love
when Britney's back [__] we love the
123 this country is obsessed with
123 you up they love you we going to
tear your ass down and then Rocky bbo us
come back they want it that that is what
we are obsessed with build up tear down
combat they like when they count you out
and so to your point and in sub
communities in subc communities gender
race religions immigrants from different
C C
countries they've got their own nuances
yeah right whether it's Jewish or Muslim
or black or white or India or from
Pakistan like they got their own little
nuances and then even within it
Detroit's different
than six six Wards different uh
Southside Atlanta there's Nuance Nuance
Nuance [__] Memphis right Harlem's
different like it's all like all these
little nuances yeah this goes back to
the number one thing I think about every
day of my life life if you're authentic
to yourself mhm not chasing every
[__] thing MH and you can [__] do
this then you can [__] win the
problem is most people can't tune out
the noise cuz they [__] want to hear
the
accolades the reason people struggle
with people's judgment on the negative
is because they get high on the positive
right the reason my [__] that's so real
you get a thousand love com the two
haters be
looking
me real [__] you guys know this I post
and I get a lot of love because of the
way I rolled and when I tell you those
9,000 goat emojis that come in comments
I can't hear them I don't think I'm
special yeah for real talk I'm aware I
got stuff we all got stuff right but
because I don't let them gas me they
can't tear me yeah see see but like so
what what I'm really saying right is I
don't I don't give a I don't care about
how they feel about that [__] I look at
like the like the the whole dynamic of
that [__] like damn this [__] kind of
throwing [__] off from the
music side however the part that I do
got a problem with like with what you
said just just resonated with me for so
so much because of the sense I got I
could have a conversation about anything
and I I lightweight be kind of like care
I do care what [__] people feel
about that part like d cuz now with
being a rapper nowadays you can't have
too much sense and the [__] just it's
just dumb [__] just garbage [__] you
know what I'm saying like we can't I
can't I can't sit down and have a
conversation about something that don't
none of my listeners or followers have
absolutely no type of understanding of
and
meanwhile the number one way for you to
enjoy the next 70 years of your life is
having as many of those different
conversations in real life as humanly
possible yeah yeah you know back to
let's you know just cuz I thought about
I just thought about him today maybe
subconsciously because Dave you're going
to be here nipy yeah was nipy because of
who he was having combos with all
right that's every one of our challenges
everybody who's in this stream right now
everyone who's going to be listening
over the next five years to this
somebody's listening to this podcast
right now in 2028 and I promise you her
number one challenge is not expanding
her world enough worrying about the
Judgment of people when you walk into
new environments like right you know
Street kid from Detroit you should go to
the [__] US Open tennis
tournament and get some different flate
like it's it it's the game you deserve
it because then the other thing is and
this is what I believe was foundational
for a lot of us when you grow up in
adversity it's the foundation of your
success you already know what losing
tastes like you're not scared of it yeah
and you're crafty yeah like that's just
real talk when like when you grow up in
a jungle you know there's animals around
the corner you grow up in a
zoo you don't and so you know what funny
I grew up in a way where I thought all
those kids that had so much were so
lucky now at 48 being grown I feel bad
for the kids that are growing up with
too much absolutely they're they're just
not prepared I got cousins like that
that's you see it we all know it and all
you know we're all to different levels
of our careers we we all of us already
at this point have been around very
successful people and and you see it and
you know I I re honestly know [__]
and I know well I say this a lot so and
I know a lot of people don't [__] with
it they're like [__] you girl that's
stupid but I'm telling you kids that
have much I feel worse for than kids
that don't on real [__] on some real how
do I feel their makeup is in their soul
I think for the parents that are
watching right now like thank God that
but you got to watch it careful cuz you
got to build them I go through yo like
my pops he never just gave nothing like
we always we always had to do something
like you know what I'm saying like and I
think about that with my own is like
damn I give give give cuz I I'm getting
it you get what I'm saying but I don't
know what I'm doing in to them in the
long run by just giving giving giving
giving like you know what I mean but I
got daughters that [__] is hard they be
got me wrapped around their finger well
yeah there's that plus I feel like if I
had a boy I might be like nah like you
know what I'm saying and the other p
my son but I I'm I'm way tougher on my
son I ain't tough at all with my little
girl I do try not to spoil them though
like real [__] and I and they got
everything they want but it's a lot of
[__] that they don't got and I do try to
make them wait for that [__] and I try
to make them work for that [__] you know
what I'm saying my son seven my daughter
eight yeah he going to be like you know
who my dad
is and yeah I I don't let bro it's a lot
of [__] that that I don't allow them to
see and look and just you know a lot
[__] and you're lucky 87 you got another
two three four years then they're going
to know everything before they start
Google search they're going to know
everything I had to edit the YouTube
they watching your I I I want to I want
to segue to something interesting I want
to give some
flowers I want to give some flowers I'm
going to give you a few seconds I'll set
this up and by the way everybody in the
chat all 500 of you right now leave some
flowers for someone and here's what I
mean by that on some real [__] I believe
the world has gotten really good at
spitting
negativity real good
negativity is loud as [__] yeah we're
walking around 24/7 hearing how hearing
something's [__] up everything loud
super loud I think algorithm hits and
and and the algorithm is a reflection of
you I'll show you my algorithm it's Jets
football it's happy kittens on Tre like
I got positivity in my feed cuz I don't
[__] with negativity like that
everyone's like the algorithms [__] me
up I'm like you're the algorithm that
[__] based on what you
[__] the algorith
I know I know honestly there's very few
things I know more than what I just said
I [__] with that though that's right you
the algorithm bro if I had any musical
Rhythm I'd be with you guys bro I got
bars I just don't know how to do the
music anyway anyway I'm going give you
some I'm going to get I'm going to give
you a minute think this through to that
point to the point of pick your kid one
time when you normally would have went
to work I'm going to do we're going to
do it right now I'm I want you to think
for a second someone that right now
publicly forever minted in this
recording give somebody love right now
maybe even someone you never really get
some random [__] like a bus like
something you've been in the back of
your head or maybe something current
somebody right now who's helping you in
some way or somebody that put you on or
somebody that really stopped you from
getting caught on some [__] somebody
right now around the circle on some I'll
go first actually I'm going to give love
to my best friend Brandon wariki who I
met the first day of high school first
day and I sold him some cards the next
day cuz that's who I am yeah but we
became best friends forever I do not
believe that I would be able to have the
career that I have this I've never said
this public get ready
Dustin I do not believe that I have the
career I have today if it wasn't for
Brandon wariki because I would have
never left my dad's store if it wasn't
in his
hands that's real real
talk I could not be me because I would
have never left my dad like that because
I wouldn't have felt good M back to
family I knew him from 14 we did
baseball card shows when we graduated
college he came in at 23 I worked with
him every [__] day retail 8:00 a.m.
to 10: p.m. 350 days a year for a decade
he's family as much as my brother and
sister and I could have never made that
leap to the next place if I didn't know
I had somebody good good cuz I my dad
needed that partner and I was that and
that was the closest thing and and so
that's my love big shout out to Brandon
wari I got to do that for my big brother
Rick okay go ahead you know I don't I
don't show enough appreciation to him at
all you know what I'm saying I grew up
with with without a father but my
brother like he way older than me and he
was that father figure for me you know
what I'm saying I and I we I grew up we
had a like a LoveHate relationship how
much older is Rick uh Rick about eight
years older than me I'm 11 years older
than my brother AJ yeah and that's why I
jumped AJ just graduated school and we
started this V media together um so I
know exactly what that relationship's
like and I I I don't appreciate I don't
show him no appreciation actually you
know what I'm saying he did a lot of
[__] for me bro like if it wasn't for
him I wouldn't be no rapper you know
what I mean he the first guy that made
me sit down and just write a rap you
know cuz he he knew the way I
appreciated music and it's a situation I
always think about this [__] I never
spoke on it when I was in uh ninth grade
right and this was the last look read
the chat look what they're saying what
they say they what they say you're
giving your flowers to Rick Owens no
Ricky Smith man my brother you got yeah
we got to clear it Up chat don't [__] it
up look I got a crazy story though right
I was in the ninth grade Bo that's the
last this the last this one I dropped
out right before I dropped out
completely so uh I was a popular kid you
know I was I was a ninth gr yeah I was a
ninth grader with a 12th grade
girlfriend you know what I'm saying I
failed all my class usually he the
reverse so that's some good [__] I
failed on my classes and I I I I knew I
was going to be in to go to the 10th
grade and still be in all ninth grade
class and my big brother sold the rims
off his car and paid for my summer
school and I dropped out that [__] I
didn't go to summer school sold the rims
off his car the rims that he sa he
worked hard for and saved up for for
months sold them [__] so I can go to
summer school just so I wouldn't feel
embarrassed and look crazy you know what
I'm saying so I didn't show no
appreciation then and I feel like I
don't show enough now I I do the whole
huh here you go type [__] you know what
I'm saying he is own man he his own boss
he got his own money you know it ain't
much I can do for him but I do do do the
financial he's about to listen to this
[__] that's this is why we're having
this show what you just did that's it to
your point for sure if if you can't give
paper because they got it like that or
one can't give it the only other thing
that really really really changes [__]
is words by the way on the record cuz
there's some grown people in here words
over paper every day yeah people want to
hear it yeah people want to [__] hear
it bro I'm proud of you that was some
deep [__] appreciate that brother who's
got something who's going with flowers
go ahead now well my mine is like mine
it isn't too like crazy like deep like
that but like I got to give appreciation
to my boy sham right here let's go cuz
when I when I met him like uh I was in a
really dark spot like mentally like he's
my producer my engineer and uh when I
had met him I was just in like a like
kind of just figuring my life out like I
just moved back from Baltimore and like
I was kind of just like not sure if I
want spending time in Baltimore will
always get you in the place it was dark
over there but I I kind Baltimore ain't
no [__] joke it big shout out to
Baltimore like if you want to T up your
kid send them to Baltimore for a year
that's a real [__] Baltimore's a real
[__] place now now you want know New
York is New York's gotten a lot softer
in the last 30 years Baltimore ain't
[__] around n it's just crazy I went
out there like uh with a girl at the
time that I was with oh now I know where
you were [__] up yeah we went we went
out there you know I crashed out in
Baltimore a little bit I made it back
though and then I met sham and then he
kind of just woke me up like on some
like like bro this is the first person I
I ever had in my life that was like
hungry for this [__] like me so like
when I when I met him I didn't realize
how hungry I even was we were just
cooking having fun in his crib like he
picked me up from work cuz I was working
at UPS yeah the first time I met him he
picked me up from UPS and I was like who
is this dude like he just picked me up
we drove to the city we cooked uh we
went to the studio we cooked some music
and like we just had a connection and
like since that day bro like me and him
have not ever like switched up on each
other there's been a time where like he
actually was like like we shot a music
video in Miami he he paid for everything
like took me to Miami like yo I believe
in you so much that like I'll invest my
own money time everything and then so
that's why we you know sh with me to the
to the end of this [__] to the end of
this beautiful [__] bro you know and he
a big part of my like everything music
like my whole music career if it wasn't
for sham I probably wouldn't be where
I'm
at here to see it n yeah for sure and he
definitely here to see it like that's
why I make sure he comes flowers Dave
what you got bro mine's uh I got to give
it to my brother big bully um speaking
about bore I did I was locked up in bore
and he was the person that was right
there to pick me up when I got out you
know what I'm saying and from that from
then on from before then but I feel like
I wouldn't have the drive or the the the
the the love I got for music if he
didn't step in my life when he did cuz
he was the first person to bring me
around all of it the studios the the
rappers that was already on I got a
chance to see all that before I like 10
years damn there before I even got on so
I would have to give it the bully you
know what I'm saying just over the years
even to this day been nothing but
supportive he was the first person to
drive me um where we went North Carolina
my first book in it was for like $500 we
drove all the way to NC drove back so he
always been from day a negative Roi
event crazy we lost money
like was but kids listen I jumped in for
a reason there think about what Dave did
he drove from [__] New York to North
Carolina for $500 a I was so
excited I'm listening to kids in my DM
right that's
right that people get people don't
people get confused when you get paid to
do something that it could be an in
investment right this is why I jumped in
I want to give something for I know one
person's going to hear what I'm about to
say and change the way they move and
it's going to change their life people
understand doing [__] for free is an
investment you tell somebody like go do
this it'll be good for you they're like
okay but when they get paid a th000 if
it cost them 1,300 to do it they're like
nah I'm lit and I'm like no no you don't
get it it's something about getting paid
for some [__] even though and you lose
money that confuses them that that's an
investment and they say no to [__] that
would have been the [__] that changed
their life every one of us as we sit
here right now said no to some [__] that
would have changed our life for the
better I think about all the people ask
me all the time with the way I roll
what's the biggest mistake you made I'm
like the ones I didn't know I made the
meeting I didn't take that would have
met to the intro that would have led me
to being the first inv don't know 100% I
can talk about passing on Uber I [__]
that up I lost 500 million I could talk
about like all the dumb business
mistakes the way I don't like that I
manage for a long time cuz I wasn't real
with people I Tred to fix them without
telling them they were [__] up and
then it got dirty I could talk about all
that I know as I sit here today
especially the way my life played out I
didn't take some random
meeting that would have been the meeting
that set up cuz the I take the meetings
when they're [__] CEO of Disney I'm
talking about the meeting and I say yes
to a ton of [__] yep that's why I win
yeah but you can't especially last 10
years I can't say yes to
everything or the or or the back to like
picking the kid over thing or Dave sends
like yo I got a release party I'm like
[__] I'm in Indiana like yo I hope it's
amazing like maybe I would should have
said yes to that not done done that
business meeting and in that meeting in
that launch party I might have met dude
and dud this dude would have like it's
the connections the biggest mistake I've
ever made is the meeting I didn't take I
like that that's a good one
like uhhuh and so I think about that a
lot what I want to go back to bully for
a second just the way you told the story
obviously the dude that picks you up
when you come out the [__] lock cell
that's that person's always going to
first face I've seen but the way you
said it you guys were just friend like
it it sounds like that took the
relationship to a whole another level no
we was locked in already like on on some
Street [__] though like it wasn't no
music or nothing nothing like that going
on at that time back to when he brought
you around I like you said something I
wanted I want people to hear this this
is what why I want by the way this is
why I'm doing this show I know that I
have such a crazy wild audience they're
all over the place because I'm all over
the place so I know that a ton of people
like I was reading when you guys first
sat down some people lose in their minds
that y'all are in here and tons of
people being who the [__] are
these and that's why I do this podcast
with friends cuz I'm trying to the
reason I'm doing this show is I'm trying
to put y'all on to new people first I
think all of you have something to say
to people in my world that you're going
to help them second there's a lot of
business people in here and it's going
to lead to [__] for y'all so I love
doing this [__] right but I want them to
be exposed to new [__] right you said
something that I want to click on he
brought you around you got to see people
that were winning M back to
flowers when you were making that
transition mhm which person do you
remember vividly out one night whether
in studio in the club on the stoop
whatever the setting was in the
boardroom who caught your attention that
was an artist that was winning what did
he or she say what did they do do you
remember an early story when bully was
bringing you around when you got to see
like Big Pun move like this or like for
instance anything stand out any I know
it's like there sometimes that really
like it's hard to recall but I'm just
curious if anything popped off on some
artist that you early on with him it
would I would have to say dip shut when
they was like in they in that Glory like
you know what I mean cuz I would I would
see them in Harlem one like not knowing
them of course then I'm with bully and
I'm seeing them in a whole another light
you get what I mean so it was like they
really rock stars like I see you know
what I'm saying just they whole demeanor
the clothes the the whole get up like
you know what I'm saying you realize oh
this is how they are behind the scenes
right 100% and I had I had a my my my
big bro was right there I'm I'm just in
the back observing just like a sponge
just soaking up game from all of them
like you know what I'm saying but seeing
that that early was like damn this [__]
might be possible let's talk about
social
media just cuz it's such a big currency
in the world yeah but the main Curren
where weot of people where yeah where
we're at everyone's got different
relationships somebody at the stable's
about to tell me they don't have any app
on their phone makes sense to me in 2024
somebody else is going to say this that
as a human and as a professional MH talk
break down social media for you right
now how are you using it what do you
like as a dude what do you like to use
from a promotional standpoint what do
you wish you've been using but you're
like scared to get in there what's
stopping you break down social media for
you right now that one I'm I I ain't
used yet that I kind of you know be
reluctant to [__] with is is the uh Tik
Tok [__] you know what I'm saying just
because just cuz what the the image TI I
got just like ain't nothing but a bunch
of danc and like just all that [__] just
[__] I ain't really interested in not
that that [__] is a bad thing to real
quick that's just one of the ones I'm
sorry I apologize I was distracted I
want to hear it one more time real real
quick TI Tok is the one I ain't like
really [__] with ch you know what I'm
saying did you think it was corny and
little girls dancing or the thing that
I'm seeing from real winners like you m
they're worried about going on there
with no followers and they're worried to
set up an account and they only got 500
or a th000 or 2,000 followers and they
think it looks bad or is it a third
thing that I didn't bring up I just feel
like I didn't have much to add to the
app you know what I'm saying like is it
because you thought you had to be silly
or do skits that's that's exactly what
it is it's I I felt like you know you if
you're not dancing or you you not making
music [__] not there was some
mixup sorry about that yeah I felt like
if it Ain you ain't making music like
that [__] can dance too and
[__] like that or ain't no jokey joke
[__] or just just whatever the [__] it
is like you know what I'm saying just
one of them um you're making a big
mistake my man yeah the only currency
for all those businesses and your music
is
attention before you can sell or get
somebody on they got to be listening
yeah attention is the only currency in
the world and the enormity of attention
on Tik Tok and back to how what you do
remarkable bro I went on Tik Tok when it
was called musically it was
only it was only 14-year-old girls I was
scared to go on on some people are going
to be like you got to go to jail [__] it
was that early and you know what the
first content was business
talk I went on Instagram and did this
yeah when nobody was doing this right
people were taking nice photos of the
skyline yeah a [__] I went in and did my
thing in the room I didn't give a [__]
what the room was doing you're giving a
[__] what the room is doing yeah I am go
on Tik Tok and make Instagram videos and
let it work out
right got me yeah bro you are too you
are too
ascending to be silent on the MTV of
this generation yeah that [__]
is MTV n right now like uh like social
media is like a short form content thing
right now like people don't even care
about music videos like unless like
obviously like it's fire but like
attention SP you go viral off a 5sec
clip you shot with your man's at your
crib before you go viral for the $20,000
it's called it's called the gate it's
the gateway drug Dr it's the gateway
drug it's like a and a curse by the way
back to if it's but if Cole Bennett
makes a [__] video I'm telling you
right now people are going to watch that
[__] oh yeah yeah yeah for Quality
matters yeah for sure but to your point
it's the [__] it's the Nick bag yeah
Tik tok's the Nick bag
yeah punching though it's definitely
punch you feel like do you feel like
social media is like a gift and a curse
though of course it's like both money
and F
exposes you it doesn't change you it's a
gift and a curse yeah the reason you all
know this cuz a lot of you had this
aspiration money and fame exposes
you now social media is doing that to
everyone no I ain't saying more so like
a gift and a curse like with with with
yourself like with ourself just more so
like the energy with social media media
just period you know what I'm saying
just just watching Everybody we're
saying the same thing a lot of people
care about [__] that just shouldn't
matter that don't matter as the old dog
hitting here pre- internet the number
one show on TV was lifestyles of the
richest famous and people gave a [__]
MTV Cribs happened before the social
media people been caring about dumb [__]
forever yeah yeah that's true it's true
cuz bro real life like this [__] [__]
like this [__] shouldn't matter bro like
just being an artist like this [__]
shouldn't matter I got it cuz I like it
but in reality bro I know I don't value
this [__] this [__] don't mean nothing
to me cuz don't make me who I am I'm a
man I'm a real [__] regardless bro
you're lucky you're lucky between
between your older brother and the
circumstances even watching you from
afar and now chopping up like you said
in here you got a good foundation you're
called secure you got self-esteem your
balance of self-esteem and insecurity is
in a good spot 90% of people on Earth's
insecurity eats them alive and whether
it's on Instagram life has always been
this it's just heighten we it just in
your face o now like before you had to
watch it on TV now you on the toilet
honly rewriting history people were
either reading a magazine or newspaper
watching TV like or talking about it in
the [__] Street Barber shops and [__]
yeah bro but you couldn't you couldn't
be in New York and see a footage of
somebody getting blown up or killed [__]
like that and somewhere fall like you
couldn't see it it wasn't as graphic and
the question but let's but guess what
let's not act like the last 200 years we
were so great so when I hear that just
couldn't see it right guess what I'm
saying maybe this is the one step
backwards for eight steps forward maybe
we need to see this shit's going on
everywhere if we ain't seeing this [__]
then we wouldn't be aware of it you
right that make hey bro got a lot of
knowledge over here [__] bodyo some
for
real CU for me it's all people it's
always and I got Lu if you looked at my
second grade photo I went to Martin
Luther K Elementary School I got real
lucky back to where we all grew up cuz
environment makes us listen to how we
all talked y yeah if you look at my
second grade photo actually team you
want to dig it up I want to post it
again soon it's crazy there's 20 kids in
it five kids are black five kids are
white five kids are Asian five kids are
Indian on real [__] yeah I wonder if
team could pull it up before you leave
it's I ain't never seen a class picture
with better diversity yeah and I got
lucky my mom taught me to love and then
I was just around all kinds of different
people and then I got that's it that's
all you need and that's what we need to
be teaching right now we're telling all
everyone to hate each other if we look
different we are religion race gender
income level what we wear and we need to
do the look at this P show look at this
picture this [__] is crazy diverse this
is fire bro that's fire this fire right
you see my little you see my little
swing this is
crazy that's fire bro and so and that's
that's why I love the internet because
the internet right now we're focusing on
what's bad on the flip side we're
getting cultured you're choosing to only
pay attention to something if you're
just looking at hot [__] all the time
that's your world yeah no yep that is
your world that's all that's going to
pop up all that's up but but if you try
to widen it you can get to everything
you want to learn how to cook how are
you going to learn how to cook pre
internet if nobody around you could
teach you how to cook true explain
that's true you go right on intern if
you want to learn how to surf like you
know what I mean if you want to like if
you want to work on your me like people
talk about all the mental [__] that F
four grown men into the [__] that we're
into with our backgrounds our exact PE
25 years ago is not talking about the
[__] we just talked about we talked
about feelings up in this [__] real
life 25 years ago we ain't talking real
[__]
[__] cool rap when I what I grew up
with cool rappers talking they want to
be better
dads get the [__] out of here that's
legendary that's legendary Right There
get the [__] out of
here being being enough of a man and
vulnerable enough to say on God right
here in this room I haven't been good
enough to my brother yeah get the [__]
out of here so I think shit's heading in
the right direction we're choosing to
look at what's not going well
But A lot's going right L going right
it's just unfortunately there's not
enough messengers of that that's why I
do this I want to be loud about positiv
here's what it is negativity is loud
because misery loves company positivity
keeps it in their Circle you know this
the most positive people are like cool
we'll just chill over here we're good
because when when you do what I do which
is you go out there and make positivity
loud and you put yourself out there you
get [__] lots of [__] heat MH yep
people want to point fingers they don't
want to point thumbs when I'm like it's
good out here that means the next thing
coming out out of my mouth is then
you're in
charge if it sucks it's cuz you are
sucking not because the president I'm so
excited I'm so excited for this
presidential election I love when the
presidents switch you know why not on
any other reason then everybody right
now who's blaming their life on Joe
Biden in a year when they still suck
don't matter
whoever for sure they're going to vote
they voted Trump then they voted for bid
Trump again they going vote for like
yeah it's up to you man you do we not
yeah you're right
toity accountability yes there's
systematic [__] it is there's racism and
sexism and there everything it's always
been though but that [__] change if
everybody individually decide to pay
more attention to their self not next
man don't like to hold themselves
accountable though I think I think the
world one thing that I I I pray get way
better right now is for everybody to be
able to accept that we all may have
different opinions and outlooks on
certain [__] but that don't mean it's a
problem that don't mean I don't I hate
you that don't mean I dislike you that
don't mean it's something that we can't
agree on I should be able to say hey bro
you like green but I think I think I
think the the Orange is is is better
problem is first of all I love you with
all my heart comma comma comma on some
real [__] green and blue is easy it's
when someone's saying some [__] about
your people yeah where we got to get the
ultimate strength is when someone shits
on your people your gender your race
your religion your town when someone
shits on your people do you have the
strength to react with trying to
understand why versus hating bad back
and right now that's true it's hate back
and we got to identify that cuz some
some things don't be a person [__]
on your people your culture your
religion it don't be a [__] some some
[__] be true you know somebody say hey
that's like that's
like like let's let's be
honest no no for sure but let's let's be
real right that's like if someone was to
be like yeah uh black onblack crime is
is at a high rate that that that [__] is
true it ain't for me to be like man why
you always got to bring that up what
about you know what I'm saying what
about this bro it's it's it's it's
[__] up black and black crime is high
that's not an insult that's a that's a
true statement let's figure out how that
person is basically saying Hey brother
with all due respect y'all Community
should maybe you know trying to figure
out some type of Peace amongst each
other and and maybe you can start that
conversation if you if you got a
positive mentality that's what you
really hearing but if you got a [__]
up mentality you really hearing you
really hear
black people hate each other they kill
each other but that's not what that
person I got to run to my next [__] I'm
going to leave it with what you just
said my dude life is how you see it if
you wake up tomorrow and say
everything's [__] up I got news for
you that whole day you were going to
find [__] that is [__] up but if you
wake up and be like yo life is good like
I'm lucky I'm even a person I could have
been a [__] Rhino or a
goldfish like let me try to find some
positivity you will find it every this
has been an hour positivity you should
see the chat this been a full hour you
can find it you just got to follow the
right [__] people anyway thank you
fellas love thank you love you love you
to
[Music]
brother